[Music]
europeans want the eu to take decisive
action to deal with the fallout of the
coronavirus pandemic
but in order to fund the recovery and
invest in the future the eu needs a more
ambitious budget
mep say this can be done with new owned
resources
small levies on things like plastic
waste
why we need to renew on results because
we
don't want to increase the national
contributions we don't want to
burden the taxpayers with the eu economy
experiencing a deep recession
parliament is calling for the level of
owned resources collected by the eu to
be permanently raised
to help fund the recovery without
burdening future generations of
europeans
foreign
have proposed a basket of options to
raise revenue without burdening ordinary
europeans
this includes a common corporate tax
attacks on digital services like
facebook or google and a financial
transaction tax
in line with the green deal parliament
is also proposing own resources designed
to fight climate change
like income from the carbon emissions
trading scheme a contribution based on
plastic waste
and a carbon border adjustment mechanism
in order to take climate action
invest in young people and fund the
recovery the eu needs to be more
self-sufficient
parliament says it will not back the
next long-term budget
unless it includes a reform of revenue
sources
you